men are
horrible I mean the next person who does
that is gonna get stabbed the species
cannot survive with a shortage of women
I need to watch stupid feminist tick
tocks like a fish needs a bicycle but
here we are I'm doing it for you so that
I can understand
the best arguments made by the feminist
ladies and none of them are good I can
respond to them I can interpret them so
that you don't need to on your own
take it away
the species can survive
with one man
this feces cannot survive with a
shortage of women
Food For Thought gentlemen
is this flirting I think this is
flirting for feminists
you know the species can survive with
one man how's that sound to you buddy
you know you you get all of us you say
oh thanks well I'm good hard pass you
know I'm married so it's okay thank you
though
but we can't survive with a shortage of
women well of course you can survive
with the shortage of women couldn't
survive with no women but the species
could survive with a shortage a
shortages of women sometimes in
different places and I don't think I'd
want to be that one man
I mean I have to just
tell it to you like it is honey but
oh man
and the key is to just find a man who's
the least horrible for many women in our
modern culture
that is probably a fair conclusion to
have drawn and it's not even the guy's
fault it's really the culture's fault
and the fault of people who make their
own bad decisions and in part the guy's
fault as well because think about what
what a great deal or maybe even most
women's experience of men is in their
lives they grow up in an age where
divorce is common we're out of wedlock
birth is common where families break
down and a lot of people don't have a
father figure in their lives so right
off the bat pretty skeptical of men then
they're put into schools and they're
told that men and women are exactly the
same and so all sense of chivalry and
gentlemanliness totally goes out the
window now women have have their
trophies taken away and their
scholarships taken away by some men
that's up for the ideology has gotten
then at some point in high school or
college maybe they enter into what is
our modern dating scene which is the
hookup culture and the hookup culture is
also predicated on the feminist idea
that men and women are exactly the same
and they react to sex in exactly the
same way but that's obviously not true
men and women have different stakes and
sex and we have of different bodies and
we have different hormones and we have
different desires and we're we're
different as individuals Body and Soul
so what happens the men get their
jollies and the women feel used and the
women are being used for sex the women
after a certain period of time they
become less sexually desirable and so
after having a slew of men just use them
up for their own selfish satisfaction
they then just kind of cast them aside
and one then what do the women do the
women are single they have a harder time
getting married if they do want to get
married and they've been told that they
have to go work outside the home they
should put off getting married they
should put off having kids they should
put off the things that naturally are
considered to be fulfilling to women and
for the women who don't want to get
married they're left working in the
widget Factory for Mr McGillicuddy
making some paltry wage they're still
working for a man who doesn't love them
who would throw them at the moment that
they're that they're no longer really
useful just like all the men that they
thought liked them back in their teens
and 20s so I get it like I why they
think men are awful but it's not the men
it's the culture and the idea and the
fact that the women are acceding to this
culture that is ultimately going to harm
them greatly right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles if you are
hiring you're probably dealing with
economic uncertainty by definition now
more than ever it is important to hire
the right people faster more efficiently
to keep overall costs down thankfully
ZipRecruiter is a hiring partner that is
focused on you and your needs from
pricing to technology everything that
zip recruiter does is for you and what
works best for you right now you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ziprecruiter's smart technology
identifies the best matches for your job
and lets you invite candidates that you
really want to apply to your job before
other businesses can snag them I
absolutely love how straightforward
their pricing is you know what you pay
for before posting your job so you can
stick to your budget with no surprises
hire the best with the help of a partner
that is all about you with the
ZipRecruiter 4 out of five employ
players who posted on ZipRecruiter get a
quality candidate within the first day
just go to ziprecruiter.com
Knowles that is ziprecruiter.com Knowles
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
I'm going to say what women have been
saying over and over for Generations
when you cannot discern who the Predator
is you're going to assume that everyone
could be the Predator to keep yourself
safe there's countless analogies about
this with sharks and snakes and lots of
other things that bite
now I'm gonna offer the men on here some
advice number one if you're following me
means you're probably not one of the
worst no person over the age of 18
should ever put ketchup bigger by
conversations about straight men being
problematic then you might actually be
one of the problems okay thanks so much
pal so this guy is the flip side to
feminists he obviously doesn't share one
of the defining features of feminists
which is a hatred of men somebody tells
me this guy doesn't he doesn't hate men
he's gay he's good
he shares a deeper defining feature of
the feminists which is the view that the
Sexes are not complementary the old view
is that men and women need each other
there will never be a war between the
Sexes because everybody's Sleeping with
the Enemy there is a tea loss to our
bodies which is to join together in holy
matrimony and then in this unique very
particular Union sex you mean sex the
love is so real that it actually becomes
another person and you you create a
child and for the feminists they hate
the men so they say no men and women are
exactly the same and there's no
distinction between us or we just don't
want anything to do with men entirely
and we're going to become lesbians or
something that escalated quickly and for
this guy he's essentially saying the
same thing saying yeah we don't men and
women don't really need each other
they're more inclined to do the opposite
sex as a predator and there are all
sorts of predators in the world but the
defining relationship between the Sexes
is not one of predation but one of love
which is kind of funny for for a group
of people that always says love wins
love love love love they don't seem to
know know anything about what love
actually means it's really funny the way
that we expect girls to just kind of
like ignore cat calling but the second
she answers back she's like being a bit
too much it's like I scream something at
me but in that I scream something back
people are like dude you just need to
let it go you need to calm down that is
just so funny to me and by funny I mean
the next person who does that is gonna
get stabbed crazy crazy crazy crazy I
know cat calling is a a trope
and a lot of women flatter themselves
and say that they walk by construction
sites and the men are whistling at them
or something like like they're in a
1920s cartoon or something like that
nice
color me a touch skeptical some of these
gals seem a little Fantastical in a lot
of their ideology and their narratives
and I just don't
don't totally buy it
wow right you know they caught a little
glimpse of her foot nuts
you saw Uncle Bo